It's a tough gig being a pollinator
these days, especially in big cities.
Land is being used differently and
that's a threat to pollinating insects.
But a new study of four UK cities
shows that increasing urbanization
doesn't have to be a death sentence.
A team of ecologists looked at nine
types of land use that make up most
of a city's area, if you exclude buildings,
roads and water which aren't much use
to pollinators anyway.
First, they counted the total number of
pollinators and plants in each area,
recording how many different
species there were as well.
The more numerous and varied the plants,
the greater the biodiversity of pollinators.
No surprises there.
Gardens held the most and
most varied pollinating insects,
but not all garden plants
are equally appealing.
Hydrangeas, daisies and forget-me-nots
were less appetising, whereas among
pollinators' favourite flowers were
dandelions, brambles and buttercups -
ones that gardeners often pull up.
Next, the researchers wanted to know
how land could be better managed
to support pollinator communities,
so they built a computer model
to test how giving more land
to each different land use
might make pollinator
networks more robust,
in other words, more
resilient to species loss.
They found that the biggest
bounce in robustness came when
they allotted more space to allotments,
even though, with the boost,
allotments still only accounted for
less than 1% of city space.
Allotments host fruits, vegetables
and weeds as well - a mix
which provides a great variety of flowers.
The researchers also wondered if
there were other ways to boost
the robustness of pollinator communities.
According to their model, this could be
achieved by planting more flowers in parks
and allowing wildflowers to grow
in verges and other green spaces.
A few simple strategies,
say the researchers,
could help support pollinators
in cities across the world.
Add more allotments,
plant flowers in parks
and don't mow the grass!